fan de johnny et pour cela ils sont
prêts à affronter vents et marées sur la
petite île finistérienne de molène un
passionné du chanteur a réuni une
extraordinaire collection qu'il expose
et il y a quasiment plus de visiteurs
que d'habitants reportage olivier sioux
et gabriel camille la guitare cassée par
johnny le blouson de johnny les
chaussures de jen elle seule exposition
vaut le détour mais alors quels détours
mollet le petit caillou posé aux confins
du finistère ce qui n'est pas peu dire
chaque jour
le bateau débarquent ces flots de
visiteurs venus rien que pour lui ce
premier robert et fabien par exemple
chez eux après le père c'est le fils qui
tout petits est tombé dans la marmite
tout et je fais que ces duels et la plus
comment pas autant que marquer à roanne
quand même à l'origine de tout il y a eu
de l'alsacien et le breton 40 ans de
passion chacun pour réunir quatre mille
objets tout n'est pas exposé ici il ya
un tiers qui est d'ailleurs resté dans
les cartons là parce que la salle est un
peu trop petit et certaines choses qui
sont restés chez moi à la maison
un peu comme le louvre quoi au fil de la
visite une paire de bottes pieusement
conservé un morceau de la vraie croix de
vie consacrée aux mêmes culte occultes
non
mais en définitif toile amour commun
pour l'artiste parce que ce qui nous
intéresse a priori c'est la vie de
l'artiste le côté c'est n'est que le
travail qui est fait autour de l'artiste
qui concerne sa vie privée sa 7 à lui
laisser un petit peu de choses parce
qu'on a déjà capturé beaucoup beaucoup
de sa vie alors on peut pas non plus
aller trop loin
passion un peu kitsch parfois toujours
émouvante et puis de toute façon on a
tous en nous quelque chose de hallyday à
molène comme ailleurs une femme oui
depuis toujours
oui votre époque notre époque toutes les
époques
johnny c'est l'idole des jeunes
éternelle de 7 à 77 ans à molène et
roanne dans son bar n'attend plus qu'une
chose qu'il lui rende visite sur son île
perdue du bout du monde
voilà le message est lancé